also have to lead four Dunkin Donuts
and a black coffee and called like I
said I'm on a steakhouse
and call it if you're talking meal if
you're talking wearing a pinch every
four Donuts in my life how slow would
you get after four Donuts you got sick
now your body just shuts down two donuts
and you feel like I've made such a bad
mistake I regret immediately no way dude
three if I'm gonna eat donuts I have at
least three that's Insanity not at least
I should say three is my my number three
Donuts at a sit down yeah like if I get
donuts for breakfast say three for
breakfast powdered sugar jelly Boston
cream
on a Sunday you're not talking a normal
weekday
I don't do it often you have pigs
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it how
often do you need three Donuts I know
like three Donuts
every few months